[Music]
good afternoon my name is Deirdre
Lawrence I'm a PhD candidate in a
division of toxicology president of the
black Graduate Student Association I
will be your mistress of ceremonies I
would like to invite father Bernard
Campbell to deliver the invocation the
dominant imagery of relationship among
human beings and between human beings
and the mysterious God of the Bible is
not that of a contract contracts bespeak
in human experience and necessarily
limited commitment they are strictly
limited to the persons who sign on
limited to both in the promises made and
the timing for the completion of the
agreement the Bible on the other hand
speaks of relationships more daringly a
whole not partial heartedness
characterizes the central image covenant
the mysterious God promises I will be
with you no matter what you do I will
remain faithful to you this indeed is
the strangest of all the gods and
humankind stunned by that fidelity is
invited to memory action and hope
remember you were once widows orphans
strangers
so now care for the weak in your midst
and do so without losing heart in that
memory passion for justice and hope we
gather to celebrate one of the
mysterious God's most faithful covenant
tours Martin Luther King jr. Lord God
you who hold all our names etched in
your hand who will not quench the
flickering flame or break the bruise it
read bolster us with your fidelity that
our memories not merely be custodians of
nostalgia for the good old days that our
passion for justice be wide and deep and
not simply the trickle of just us and
that through all the bitterness of human
folly help us to remain of one mind and
heart with you amazed at the dignity of
the human person made in your likeness
and image amen
now turquoise gozman a student in the
MIT Wellesley Upward Bound program from
Cambridge region Latin High School will
extend a warm welcome to president vest
and to our esteemed guest speaker judge
Higginbotham and to the other members of
today's program and to you our audience
I bid you a fond good afternoon my name
is turquoise gozman I'm a student in the
MIT Wellesley Upward Bound program and a
sophomore at Cambridge in July in high
school it is indeed a privilege and an
honor to welcome all of you to mi t--'s
21st annual celebration of the life of
dr. Martin Luther King jr. I am honored
to be included in the special
celebration for such a wonderful civil
rights leader we've come here today to
show our appreciation for someone whose
work and talents seem to be remembered
only on one day in January and during
Black History Month dr. Martin Luther
King and his beliefs should be
remembered every day this was a man with
the great civil rights leader he tried
to make a better lives for all races
this is not a man who believed that
there were only black and white races
dr. King was a man who believed that all
races were equal and deserve recognition
and respect no Martin Luther King jr.
was a colorblind but he choose to be
Martin Luther King did this in hopes
that we as a nation would see people for
who and what they are and not judge
people by the color of their skin there
are many words I could use to describe
this unique individual but I don't think
they would or could sum up to what a
remarkable person he was to those of you
who have known dr. King you are blessed
to your memories of him but for
teenagers like myself and that children
of the future
I pray that Martin Luther King's dream
lives on and so I leave you with a quote
from dr. King's address then
and dream and there is another thing we
see in this dream that ultimately
distinguishes democracy and our form of
government from all the totalitarian
regions that emerge in history it says
that each individual has certain basic
rights that are neither conferred by nor
derived from its necessary from the
state to discover where they came from
it is necessary to move back behind the
dimmest of eternity for they are
god-given very seldom if ever in the
history of the world has social
political document expressed in such a
profoundly eloquent and unequivocal
language the dignity and the worth of
human personality the American Dream
reminds us that each man is heir to the
legacy of worthiness so please sit back
and relax as we focus on today's
celebration theme the trumpet of
conscience dr. Martin Luther King's
contract with America
thank you
[Applause]
allow me to bring your attention to
Chris Richman who is a student in the
department of computer science and
electrical engineering he will accompany
us as we stand together and sing lift
every voice and sing we're gonna sing in
the first and third verses and the words
are printed on the back of your program
[Music]
[Applause]
I am pleased to announce that another
segment has been added to our program
and that is the presentation of the dr.
Martin Luther King jr. leadership award
this award is presented to MIT graduates
who have distinguished themselves by
incorporating dr. King's legacy in their
professional careers and through
community action the award committee
also recognizes individuals and groups
within the MIT community whose
achievements exemplify the ideals of dr.
King by the contribution to MIT and the
broader community at this time I call
upon provost mark Righton to make the
first presentation to Professor Robert
Mann
it's a great honor for me to make the
first presentation of this important
series of awards and to such a
distinguished individual as dr. Robert W
man I'd like to ask dr. Mann to come
forward as I introduce him to you he
will be making a few remarks in just a
moment dr. Mann is a longtime
contributor to the MIT community
retiring only just a couple of years ago
as Whitaker professor he continues a
very active set of activities on behalf
of the Institute and in his personal
life he began an interest in technical
activities early on in his life he
graduated in 1942 from the Brooklyn
Technical High School as you can
appreciate 1942 was a difficult time for
the country he went to work shortly
thereafter as a draftsman at the Bell
Laboratories and then joined the Army in
1943 in 1946 he concluded his service in
the army having worked in the teletype
and cryptographic maintenance activities
in the western Pacific Theater and then
he commenced what became a truly
distinguished career at MIT he received
his bachelor's degree in 1950 continued
on for the master's degree and concluded
in terms of formal education with the
Doctor of Science in 1957 already a
member of the faculty for several years
by that time he was promoted up through
the ranks and concluded his career as
I've indicated as Whitaker professor
during this distinguished career he
became extremely well recognized for his
contributions in the department of
mechanical engineering as an educator
and as a researcher he was named to the
National Academy of Sciences the
National Academy of Engineering
the Institute of Medicine just several
of his distinguished honors here at MIT
he received the Killian faculty
achievement award our highest award for
the faculty in 1983 and in 1983 to 1984
he served the Alumni Association as its
president he has more than 320
publications
patents and a number of his activities
in the professional arena have
contributed to aiding the blind and
assisting the disabled his work in
biomechanics can be credited with
creating an entire new field of human
endeavor professor Mann has also been a
very important contributor to his
community in the town of Lexington he
served as a member of the town meeting
from 1954 through 1958 he was director
of the Interfaith housing corporation
for 10 years and he has continued that
kind of service within the MIT community
as well in recognizing him as a Martin
Luther King junior Leadership Award II
we recognized a large number of years an
enormous amount of service in connection
with these celebratory events indeed a
few years back at a time when this
activity was at a low point he
encouraged then president Paul Gray to
reinvigorate this program and Robert man
can be credited with the enormous
success that we have realized now for
more than 20 years let me now make the
award presentation the massachusetts
institute of technology Reverend dr.
Martin Luther King jr. Leadership Award
is presented to dr. Robert W Mann class
of 1950 at MIT whose achievements and
contributions exemplify the ideals of
dr. King
February 10th 1995
I am of course greatly pleased and
honored in fact humble in you know
addressing you after that introduction
and with the significance of the first
time recipient as a faculty member of
this recognition and I had a little
notice and I'm told I have two minutes
and I've debated a bit as to quite how
to handle that and I haven't vetted the
most recent version with my wife but
hello let me let me try it this way the
suggestion was that I relate aspects of
my career that overlapped out of the dr.
Martin Luther King jr. I had the great
privilege not many of you out there I
think can share a certainly the young
people can't of personally having heard
dr. Martin Luther King when he addressed
the people of Lexington in the 1960s at
the Lexington high school but I think we
share some other dimensions which I am
convinced has put me here in this
position with this recognition today to
begin with we both come out of a
tradition religious tradition that is
and again entering its third millennia
which is committed to the belief that
every human being from conception on is
a unique individual and as such as
deserving of the respect of all other
human beings we perhaps have somewhat of
a shared experience in in origins I grew
up in a tough but nevertheless
multicultural and multi-religious
section of Brooklyn New York East New
York and early on was aware of the
variety of colors and religions
postures that people had so as I accept
this award I guess I want to say I do so
with the realization that it was easy
for me
relatively easy for me to experience the
kind of opportunities that I had or
capture you utilize the kind of
opportunities that were presented to me
because of this background of both
religious conviction and of early and
development these were of course greatly
strengthened and matured to through my
now almost 45 years association with
Margaret man and very exciting years in
the 60s when Vatican 2 was in process
when Martin Luther King was on the march
that you've all know about when our
curates in our parish in Lexington were
arrested for marching in North Carolina
it's a very exciting time so it's easy
for me to have played the role that I
have and what I want to do is accept the
award in the name of all of you there
and elsewhere who could equally well be
here with me or replacing me on this
occasion many of you whom have not had
the same kind of opportunity and
development maturation motivations that
I have had the privilege of enjoying as
I have pursued the various activities
that provost Righton has so graciously
described thank you very much
[Applause]
now I will ask president vest to present
the award to dr. Cynthia McIntyre and to
Asus Nesby and ship dr. McIntyre would
you like to join me it's my pleasure and
privilege to present for additional 1995
Martin Luther King jr. Leadership Awards
which are being given as you know for
the first time this year Martin Luther
King Committee developed this concept to
recognize past and present members of
the MIT community whose activities
exemplify the ideals of dr. King this
year we are presenting awards both to
individuals and to student groups the
individual recipient is dr. Cynthia
McIntyre why don't you step out into the
light not back in the shadows Thank You
dr. McIntyre pursued her PhD research
here at MIT in the area of condensed
matter physics in addition to her
academic work dr. McIntyre served as a
member of the physics graduate student
graduate committee and also as a
resident dormitory counselor however one
of her primary contributions was
originating and organizing the National
Conference of black physics students she
had noted the small number of black
physicists in both academia and industry
and wanted to increase that number by
reaching out to students still in the
initial stages of their academic careers
the conference brought together
undergraduate physics students from
colleges and universities nationwide to
discuss career options and career
strategies the conference was a
resounding success and since has become
an annual event held at different
universities around the country with
attendance rising to over 200 dr.
McIntyre
has provided leadership vision and
support for the conference throughout
this entire period and has done so with
her characteristic energy creativity and
above all passion for making a
difference in the lives of young people
and of somewhat older institutions dr.
McIntyre it's truly a pleasure to
present this plaque to you and the
accompanying honorarium
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King junior
Leadership Award presented to dr.
Cynthia R McIntyre class of 90 whose
achievements and contributions exemplify
the ideals of dr. King 10 February 1995
[Applause]
I to thank the committee for selecting
me for this honor I'm very grateful and
proud to have this one thing I wanted to
say Leo told me that I have one minute
to speak on this is that dr. King's
legacy had a tremendous impact on our
educational system particularly higher
education you can see throughout the
country that our universities are quite
diverse
whereas 20 to 30 years ago the dominant
institutions academic institutions did
not have a substantial number of
minority students in their programs but
now they do and that's part of dr.
King's legacy another part of dr. King's
legacy is the growth of the number of
PhDs in physics over the 20 year or so
period since the 60s and 70s during that
time the physics department here at MIT
made a commitment that they would have
black students in their PhD program and
so during that time they graduated quite
a few and a lot of you don't know the
statistics but if you delved in a little
bit you would find out that there are
three institutions in the United States
that have graduated most of the PhD
black PhDs in physics and MIT is one of
those schools the other is Howard
University and the other one is Stanford
so MIT has made a tremendous
contribution to the black scientific
community in the area of physics
when I was here as a graduate student a
group of us got together and decided to
put on this conference and we said well
how are we going to pull this off
we need money we need money and we need
money to get students here and and to
get this started so what we did we had a
little plan together and we went to the
chairman of our department dr. Jerome
Freeman would you would you stand up
please
and we said dr. Friedman we want to put
on this conference it's a national
conference we think we can get maybe 40
or 50 students here for this and here's
a budget for it he didn't say well come
back tomorrow next week
he said it's done we'll do this I'm
calling the Dean who at the time was
Dean Brown he said I'm sure the Dean is
going to back this from the physics
department you have a commitment today I
will get back to you tomorrow
and let you know where the Dean said and
we've been off and running ever since
thank you thank you for your support
they asked the three presidents to join
me now please all three of you three
professional organizations also were
nominated for awards these are the
American Indian science and engineering
society the National Society of black
engineers and the Society of Hispanic
Professional Engineers since 1990 these
three organizations have jointly
sponsored a career fair at MIT for the
entire student body the event has become
the largest student sponsored career
fair at the Institute the sixth fair
will be held later this month on
February 23 and 24 these three
organizations representing students from
various ethnic groups have worked
together for the benefit of the entire
student body they show by example what
can be done when different groups work
together for common goals and Davis Shaw
associate director of the Office for
career services and professional
advising said of these groups and I
quote their effort and cooperation have
exceeded most other professional
organizations that I've advised over the
past twenty five years I would say that
this is the case the whole is truly more
than the sum of its parts and we are all
the better for it I'm very pleased to
have the privilege to present plaques an
honor area to the presidents of these
three groups - Steven T York of the
American Indian science and Science
Engineering Society
to Sherita d williams the National
Society of black engineers and to Jeff o
Gonzalez the Society of Hispanic
Professional Engineers congratulations
to all of you
[Applause]
Thank You president vest for the award
on behalf of Asus my name is Todd York
president of MIT chapter of the American
Indian science and engineering society
currently I am a junior in chemical
engineering first let me give you some
background information on the beginnings
of the career fair the idea for the
career fair came about from a mutual
need between our respective communities
and one administrator we three
organizations Asus Nesby and Ship felt
that we should provide our members and
the MIT community with opportunities
beyond their academic life at the
Institute these would include graduate
school a necessary component for
students of color to succeed in the
workforce and job opportunities with
government and private organizations the
career fair would be a culmination of
events throughout the academic year
as organizations we knew that's that the
success of our members would not only
depend on information received in the
career fair but also in the development
of skills that can be used in a variety
of fields with the resources of the
Institute we would assist our members
with national fellowships for graduate
school resume writing skills and
interviewing techniques it would also be
important for all three organizations to
work together as a group to maximize
Institute resources and more importantly
to learn from each other it would be
this cooperation from these three very
different professional organizations
that we'd be critical to the success of
the career fair once again on behalf of
Asus let me thank the president and the
Planning Committee for this leadership
award thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone my name is
Sherita Williams I'm president of the
MIT chapter of the National Society of
black engineers and a junior in
electrical engineering I would like to
share with you the uniqueness of the
career fair and how it relates to dr.
King's legacy our minority career fair
is a joint effort between three very
different organizations each with his
own mission membership and programs
still we have crossed social barriers
and put aside individual differences to
come together and produce the single
most important financial event for each
of our organizations each group shares
both the responsibilities and the
rewards every February when over 60
companies come to MIT seeking their
Future Leaders the membership of Asus
Nesby n' ship are truly helping to
fulfill dr. Martin Luther King's dream
because part of the dream is for people
of different ethnic backgrounds to work
together as brothers and sisters toward
common goals and shared success our
collaboration for the career fair is not
our only testament of dedication towards
this Brotherhood we have also worked
together to host a very successful
social for the entire minority community
and we've joined forces several times
recently to address problems common to
the minority community at MIT although
we still have a long way to go before we
see African Americans Native Americans
and Hispanics sitting together for lunch
we have made significant progress and
reaching out to one another for common
issues again I would like to thank
everyone on behalf of Nesby aces and
chip for recognizing our efforts with
this award
again my name is Jeff Gonzalez I'm the
president of ship the Society of
Hispanic Professional Engineers a dream
is a beautiful vision that a dream is a
beautiful vision that looks beyond what
you can see then lifts you and guides
you and grow strong inside you to help
you be all you can be as we approach the
27th anniversary of dr. King's passing
we still are looking to achieve his
dream as we confront obstacles in our
way is the role of organizations such as
aces Nesby and ship to show that we can
work cooperatively to lead the way in
removing these barriers dr. King's
legacy has given us an opportunity to
learn at an institution as renowned as
MIT I feel it is our obligation to
continue his ideals and assist those who
will follow however I don't always see
the sense of commitment from my fellow
students to reverse this we must follow
dr. King's dreams and ideals because as
he stated freedom is never voluntarily
given by the oppressor it must be
demanded by the oppressed on behalf of
aces lesbian we would like to thank
president best and his planning
committee for the dr. Martin Luther King
jr. celebration activities for this
leadership award we also like to thank
our respective advisers and all the
members of the three organizations past
and present and finally we invite you to
attend our sixth annual career fair to
be held February 24th at DuPont museum
from 12:00 to 6:00 p.m. thank you
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to introduce professor
Marcus Thompson who is the first
recipient of the Robert R Taylor
professorship today he will be joined by
MIT students to perform the musical
selection music of morning the students
that will be joining him are Julia
agreed agreed easyacc Donald young Danny
you Joelle Dawson Leonard Kim and David
Riley
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you that that was amazing
[Applause]
at this time I'd like to invite
president vest to give his welcome
remarks and he will introduce our
keynote speaker as I look over the past
year I can take note of several people
and programs that make this celebration
much more than simply a one-day event
some are causes for celebration and all
are causes for inspiration inspiration
to work harder and to work together to
achieve a greater racial and ethnic
harmony and a greater social and
economic justice in our society I
suggest that we dedicate this year's
ceremony to one such source of
inspiration to bill Ramsey whose death
last month was so unexpected bill was
executive director of special programs
in the School of Engineering in
particular he was responsible for the
administration of the meit's program
which stands for minority introduction
to engineering and science and the
engineering internship program in which
students combine academic programs with
on-the-job experience bill was the very
model of dedication professionalism
honesty caring and fairness he was a
mentor and a role model to literally
hundreds of our students their success
and contributions to society are Bill's
legacy his death is a tragic loss to his
many friends and family here in to this
institution as well
Bill's work and his way of working are
sources of inspiration to all who strive
for a better society our society of
course begins right here on our campus
this is where we begin and what I think
we need to do much more than we have
been doing is to build coalitions among
the individual groups that make up our
community
because working for equity and justice
is not the responsibility of any one
person or any one organization or any
one cultural group in fact we simply
won't succeed if different groups
whether African Americans Asian
Americans Hispanic Americans or white
Americans work on these issues in
isolation from each other now working
together in coalition's is not always
indeed not often a comfortable
experience it means that you bring your
ideas and your interests to the table of
course but that they don't carry any
more weight than those of the others it
means that some interests may be in
conflict with each other
it means having to listen really listen
to what others say about their
experiences and their expectations it
means learning from differences it means
learning to trust and then working to
find common ground this is hard work so
why should we do it
the answer is simple there is no other
way there are those who ask why we
should bother trying to build racial and
ethnic relations at all why not just
live and let live I would guess that
different people have different answers
to that question but for me the answer
is quite simple we need each other there
are more problems in the world than
there is time to list them but one thing
is clear successful resolution of the
problems getting in the way of social
equity economic justice public health or
environmental health just to name a few
requires people to work together you
can't solve the problems of this
complexity and this magnitude and scale
by yourself whether you refers to a
single organization a profession a class
or even a race we are realizing this
more and more in the way we teach and
learn not only is learning in teams
whether it be in the 270 design contest
or the team's work experimental program
in chemistry often more effective it's
much more like the world
which our students will live and work
after graduation so yes we need each
other not only to solve problems but to
grow to grow in our understanding of the
world around us and the world within us
everyone in this room can expect to live
and work and we're in a world filled
with people of different cultures races
nationalities whether you stay right
here at the Institute or live halfway
around the world if we were to make the
most of this world and what it has to
offer professionally socially and
ethnically we need each other and it's
worth the struggle it's worth the work I
believe very much it's an investment
that will pay off there are many on this
campus who are making just this kind of
investment one of course as you see
today is the planning committee for the
Martin Luther King jr. memorial
activities these men and women from many
parts of the Institute do not see change
in narrow terms not only do they plan
this annual ceremony as you've heard
they initiated the awards program that
we just inaugurated and it was their
proposal that led to the very recently
announced Martin Luther King jr.
visiting professor program the goal of
this program is to enhance and recognize
the contributions of minority scholars
by increasing their presence and
interaction here on the MIT campus we
hope to appoint several such visiting
scholars each year we expect that they
will deeply engage themselves in the
intellectual life of the Institute
through teaching public lectures
seminars research and scholarship this
program will have a significant effect
on the number of minority scholars who
join our faculty ultimately on a
permanent basis another group that is
making a solid investment in our future
as a campus community is the committee
on campus race relations MIT announced
the establishment of this committee at
last year's Martin Luther King ceremony
in its first year the committee drawn
from a
broad cross-section of our community has
done a great deal to help build the very
kinds of coalition's I've mentioned
beginning with its own membership beyond
that it has published a guide to studies
and racial ethnic and intercultural
relations at MIT a document that is in
itself an impressive indication of
faculty commitment and student interest
in these areas the committee also has
established a grants program which is
even in its first year has funded
lectures arts activities cultural and
ethnic events dorm based activities
workshops conferences and undergraduate
seminars all with the underlying aim of
enhancing race relations on our campus
these are the two small examples of the
work that we all need to do there are
many many others as you know but we need
still more people to make the commitment
and to make the investment that will
turn our campus ever-increasingly into a
true community and now it is a very
special privilege to introduce today's
keynote speaker man of many facets who
has devoted his career to the pursuit of
racial harmony equity and justice it is
truly a great honor to have professor a
Leon Higginbotham with us today he is of
course a truly distinguished jurist the
chief judge emeritus of the United
States Court of Appeals for the third
District but he is also a teacher and a
scholar
currently as public service professor of
jurisprudence at Harvard University and
he has served as an adjunct faculty
member at several leading universities
throughout our nation he is an author
and a historian his book in the matter
of color race and the American legal
process the colonial period received
several national and international
awards for the quality of its
scholarship he continues his
with the practice of law serving as
counsel to paul weiss rifkind wharton &
garrison in new york's in their new york
and washington offices
let me say finally and rather personally
the professor Higginbotham is a true
friend and colleague to our institution
many here today will recall that a few
years ago the Justice Department brought
an antitrust action against MIT in the
Ivy League universities alleging
collusion in the way we awarded
financial aid to students we on the
other hand argued that our practices
sought to ensure that students would be
awarded financial aid solely on the
basis of their need and that different
schools would not get into financial
bidding wars for students we lost in the
first round of that legal battle back in
the fall of 92 but we appealed it and
that's where Leon Higginbotham stepped
forward he had retired earlier in that
year from the appeals court in
Philadelphia which in fact was the one
hearing the case he returned to appear
before that very Court on behalf of the
Philadelphia school system the Urban
League of Philadelphia and the Coalition
of Bar Association's of Hispanic black
and Asian American attorneys in the
Philadelphia area these groups I quote
judge Higgenbotham is saying these
groups are the council for the interests
of those bright and very needy students
who would be most adversely affected by
the lower court ruling he told the panel
of judges we have in this case public
service and ethical norms and what are
those ethical norms they are that those
people who are weak and those people who
are poor but who are talented should
have the same opportunity to have an
entry into these great universities as
did the Kennedys and the Rockefellers
and the Cabot's and the lodges this
concern for ethics inequity permeates
Leon Higginbotham's life and his work he
will speak to us today of a contract
with America that we would do well as
nation to honor his Martin Luther King's
contract with America ladies and
gentlemen please join me in welcoming
judge Leon Higginbotham
[Applause]
dr. vas Provost's right and the members
of the MIT community who have made such
a significant difference I was a
profoundly moved in a way in which I
seldom and when dr. McIntyre mentioned
the chairman of the physics department
who said it's done because it's a
classic example of what administrators
can do they can help us solve the
problem or they can filibuster as to why
it is so impossible to solve it at the
age of 16 years old I was interested in
physics and I was interested in
electrical engineering and I had as a
poor boy the temerity to believe that I
could make a difference as an engineer
and I went to Purdue University and at
Purdue they were 13 as we called them
then colored or maybe Negro but never
black students and we stayed at a place
which was called International House
International all the black kids at an
International House well let me tell you
about the luxury we had in the
International House we all slept in an
attic with no heat and doing those
bracing terrible biting winter nights
we'd go up to bed with shoes on earmuffs
two or three layers of pants
hoping that we would then be able to be
warm enough the next morning to go and
study about the desk chlorination of
flora tetracycline and to study all of
the challenges which we have and one
night I felt that I could not stand
another day and I talked to my fellow
student and suggested that we should
visit dr. Elliot who was then president
of the university I won't get into the
side details
everyone was unanimous that a protest
should take place that I should be
chairman and we would all show up while
I went in I arranged the appointment and
then the next day I went 15 minutes
before the time I was supposed to meet
the president my one shirt was ironed I
had done it my shoes polish my
fingernails clean my mother she was a
domestic kid always stressed upon me of
making the best of what you have and I
went in to see dr. Elliot it was 10 of
10 it was 5 of canned it was 3 of 10 and
all of these militant students who were
going to meet me there
for some reason got tied up in some
laughs or something and Here I am
meeting the president
he says pick him off and what do you
want it wasn't welcomed I said dr.
Elliot every day colored soldiers are
dying fighting Hitler and Hirohito for
what President Roosevelt calls
for four freedoms and we are freezing in
that dorm and we want to be good
students is it possible that we could
have a section of the dorm
I wasn't pressing to get the place
integrated just a section of the dorm
where we could be like the others and be
warm and Elliot looked at me and said
Higginbotham the law doesn't require us
to have you here you either take it or
leave it
and I walked out recognizing the
profound contradictions the preamble of
the Constitution said we the people of
the United States but in dr. Elliot's
eyes there were we the people and we the
other people and I was part of the other
people and ultimately I left though I
was performing quite well academically
and transferred to Antioch College and
went on to Yale Law School if dr. Elliot
had said to me with the chairman of your
physics department it's said good
morning I would have felt a little
better and if he had even said to me
well Higginbotham I don't know whether
we can do it but we ship blunt no and
when I sometimes think of why there
aren't more scientists and more
engineers today it's because of the
experiences which so many of us had in
the 1940s it did not seem to be a viable
option
so when MIT got involved with its
difficulties when the United States
Department of Justice when it had the
opportunity to challenge all of these
merge
is going on with conglomerates global
conglomerates and did not challenge them
and as the country was becoming more
oligopolistic all of the time dick
thornburgh the Attorney General of the
United States a few weeks before he's
about ready to resign and run for
Senator of Pennsylvania filed suit
against the Ivy League schools
challenging the type of arrangement they
had which I assure you meant that need
came first and therefore if you base it
on need more and more students could
come in need for students who'd already
been accepted and for some strange
reason which I shall never know the
Department of Justice during the dalish
administration prosecuted prosecuted
they hate Ivy League schools and MIT and
then the speech which I will give for
your book I have the extensive comments
of the newspapers throughout the country
which looked at this suit and thought
that it was incredulous the New York
Times described the suit as a
destructive claim unworthy of litigation
the Washington Post's at the case
against the Ivy League and its friends
may be good sport but it's bad policy
the Los Angeles Times and an editorial
on May 24th called it pure lunacy and
the Boston Globe characterized it as a
twisted interpretation of the Sherman
Act and I could go on yet when I was
approached the case had not been won
even though you had the most able and
extraordinary
attorneys representing MIT who had made
arguments which I submit to you were
irrefutable and when it was suggested
that maybe that I would go in as counsel
for the Amika
pro bono publico that means for the
public good and I'm pleased to say
without any compensation and I thought
that this was an opportunity for me to
say to a school which was treating
students differently than the way dr.
Elliot treated me that you are on the
right path and that pluralism is
important in America and that if you
allow this antitrust suit to prevail
would mean that children who were needy
or students who were needy who could not
meet the extraordinary tuition may not
make it because if you just distribute
the pot in some random fashion one
person may be getting 15,000 when they
only meet ten and if you keep doing that
for several it means that on the other
end in a world of limited resources
those who were poor and needy would drop
out and we were fortunate enough to be
successful last year was a great year
for me my two most important clients did
not pay me MIT and Nelson Mandela
but both have made profound differences
in this world I don't know why my good
friend Clarence Williams of was so
generous to ask me to come back here to
speak again I've been in this auditorium
more than once I spoke at your tribute
13 years ago for Martin Luther King and
at that time Ronald Reagan was in his
first term as president at that time no
one knew then the Dan Quayle did not
know how to spell the word potato and at
that time we M Jefferson Clinton was not
known outside of Arkansas the Soviet
Union was still a formidable adversary
and Nelson Mandela was serving the 19th
year of his lifetime sentence breaking
and chipping stone at the cruel Robben
Island penitentiary and in 1983 I
thought that even then that the
conditions for the weak and the poor
were bleak and I was not convinced that
that safety net which President Reagan
had assured us was there would be
holding up the homeless the hungry and
the poor and I said how can you talk to
one of the most sophisticated audiences
in the world you've got to not harangue
them and you know how can you give them
something which we can all relate to an
abstract so I asked the audience to
imagine and to assume that the MIT
Department of astronomy was the most
able in the world and there were no
dissents and I suggested to them that
maybe it was possible
that this great department had developed
the capacity to do electronic
eavesdropping in heaven in that place I
would not take time to define and if you
don't know where it is and you don't
believe there is a heaven it would be
waste of my time to stress it to you but
then I worked up a conversation and
imaginary counter conversation was a
fantasy I know that your extraordinary
department had gotten the electronic
eavesdropping system working and then we
heard a conversation between Martin
Luther King and Tom Jefferson and we
heard King speaking to Thomas Jefferson
he said mr. Jefferson since we have such
equality here in heaven do you mind if I
call you Tom now tom how is it that
individuals who are as philosophical and
profound as you and his bravest George
Washington as eloquent as Patrick Henry
to treat an entire group of people
non-whites with such special harshness
and cruelty solely because of the color
of their skin and there is this
fascinating dialogue where Jefferson
admits that he was wrong and he thanked
st. Peter for the affirmative action
program they had in heaven
to bring a little more diversity and to
get some lawyers and politicians in
there because there was such a shortage
and now 13 years later I stand before
you the presence of an audience
equally as sophisticated and I did not
know what I could say what I should say
but yesterday morning I had another
mystical a miraculous experience I give
it to you with some trepidation because
I don't know how many of you are
believers but I was reading the paper
while drinking a cup of coffee in my
study I had the television on on CNN and
I was reading about the OJ Simpson case
and then I gradually became aware of the
television in front of me had stopped
transmitting its usual message I am so
cheap that I have a black and white
television and my study and instead the
screen was multicolored and as I tried
to find tune the screen by playing
around with the remote control suddenly
there were series of scenes which began
to unfold and I saw the image of a white
building frame with columns and
surrounded by greenery the camera
started to move towards a building and
suddenly I had a view of the interior
and in the interior it had on it the
Abraham Lincoln and Thurgood Marshall
seminar room in heaven and the door
swung open as if by some mysterious
force and inside I saw
the interior of this seminar room and on
the blackboard written in huge black
letters were the following seminar at
noon today Martin Luther King speaker
circuit Marshall moderator a Leon
Higginbotham jr. transmitter and I could
not believe my eyes
here was King on the podium and in the
audience were people whom I admired so
greatly so journey truth and Earl Warren
and Charles Hamilton Houston William
Henry hasty and Abraham Lincoln and a
whole series of individuals rabbi prints
who've made a great difference and as I
saw this I started to wonder was I going
through some unusual syndrome my wife
had been telling me that I'm working too
hard and then after seeing this my fax
machine would on automatically and we
always have white paper and coming out
on our fax machine was blue paper and
the fonts were larger than any I thought
our facts had a capacity for and on the
front page there were just two words
from heaven and on the second page in
slightly smaller type was the byline for
Martin Luther King jr. entering class of
1968 the printer was going so fast that
the paper was almost ablaze it was so
hot that I could not hold it comfortably
in my hand and nevertheless I'd read
every word and just after I finished the
last page suddenly with all of the ink
the
appeared the paper started to
disintegrate and to ashes and the
tv-screen
reverted back making reference to the
next day of trial with OJ dazed and
confused I rushed to my desk and started
scribbling down the miraculous events I
just witness now I cannot provide you
any documentation any independent
corroboration as to what I saw from
heaven or my TV screen and the Fox paper
went into ashes which cannot be
reconstructed but I'm confident that I
saw Martin Luther King speak and through
the television I received a commentary
from him that he wants me to transmit to
you and to Newt Gingrich and it is
exactly what I would expect it to see
and hear from dr. King and let me
describe to you how it starts my dear
brothers and sisters I prepared my
commentary for this afternoon as an open
letter to my fellow citizen of Georgia
Newt Gingrich and I'm hoping that my old
friend Leon Higginbotham will forward it
to him soon and deliver the substance of
my comments and this lecture today at
MIT more important I hope thoughtful
Americans will recognize what may very
well be one of the most tragic hopes and
potential cruelties that could take
place in America under what mr. Gingrich
caused the contract with America
the letter goes dear mr. Gingrich
as a citizen of Georgia presumably I
should first congratulate you on your
election to speak of the house this is
an extraordinary opportunity for you to
increase the quality of justice and
fairness for all Americans at the same
time it also provides you with the
opportunity to further polarize our
nation to make us meaner than we've ever
been before and to disregard the plight
of the weak in the poor who do not have
political club it is within your power
to make our nation either more fair than
there's ever been in recent decades or
to make it more mean particularly upon
the powerless victims of our nation you
can exalt us to become a great nation
you can cause us to become an
increasingly divisive nation and thus I
read every page of your contract with
America by you and representative Dick
Armey who does not always speak well of
individuals when he disagrees with and
what I noticed was on the back of your
book you seem to say what the issues are
in fact that's the word you use among
the pressing issues addressed in this
important book are balancing the budget
stopping crime reforming welfare
reinforcing families enhancing fairness
for seniors strengthening national
defense cutting government regulation
promoting legal reform considering term
limits reducing taxes and I went through
every page of your book let me make it
perfectly clear I'm against crime and I
favor fair law enforce
and I favor the work ethic for our
people gave to this country two
centuries of labor without a paycheck
and we have worked most of us whenever
we could find it to make the world
brighter for the future and I recognize
that there may be some abuses of welfare
and that to the extent that those abuses
can be eliminated I favor that but what
scared me so much as I looked at all of
the issues which you said that were
important in this so-called contract
with America
not once do you say that you want to
eradicate racial discrimination not once
do you say that you want to eradicate
gender discrimination not once do you
say that we recognize that when Thomas
Jefferson said we hold these truths to
be self-evident that all men are created
equal and they're endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
and among these are life liberty the
pursuit of happiness
not once do you say Jefferson made the
pledge and he failed because when he
said men he meant all men not women when
he said men he meant men not women but
when he said men he did not include
those who were plugged therefore I
wanted to see with your reference to all
of the historic figures that you would
have in all of those chapters just one
which said that you are for a fair
Society for the powerless and the only
time you use fairness and your inter
Table of Contents is fairness for senior
citizens that disturbs me it's not that
I want unfairness for senior citizens
but you talk in terms of the good old
days
now Newt you know you and I are both
from Georgia and I've got to figure out
when were these good old days about
which you speak
I'd suggest that you go and read a case
called Cummings versus Richmond County
Georgia and in 1899 that County closed
up the only black high school in the
county because it said that if it spent
the money for the kids and high school
it wouldn't be able to put on a budget
for 400 elementary school kids to get an
education you funded high school for all
white girls and you subsidized a high
school for white boys but in Georgia the
state was willing to eliminate
educational opportunities and it wasn't
until the late 1920s and the whole state
of Georgia
but there was one public high school
open for colored people and I would have
felt so much better if you had spoken
recognizing something about the corridor
of history and saying that you stood
firm and condemnation of those abuses
that the federal resources should be
utilized to stop it firm perpetuate from
being continued now I know
Newt you have never had to be denied
service at a Woolworths
five-and-ten-cent store when you went in
to get a hotdog or a bottle of coke but
for hundreds of thousands of black
people throughout our land and
particularly in the south they couldn't
even get a hotdog and a bottle of soda
if they wanted to sit at the counter at
these lunch counters throughout I would
think that you would be concerned about
that and knowing this history but you
would be willing to make it clear where
you stood now maybe you say that I'm
getting too anxious maybe you say that I
don't know what happened in America what
I know is that when we were marching to
get access to public accommodation
sheriff dogs were biting us and sheriffs
hoses were being put on us George Bush
in 1964 said he was against the Civil
Rights Act and Ronald Reagan and 64 said
he was against the Civil Rights Act and
Strom Thurmond said he was against the
Civil Rights Act all claiming that it
was unconstitutional therefore does your
contract mean to turn back to America to
the world which Thurman and Bush and
Reagan wanted in 1960
for you never had to march from Selma to
Montgomery to make a poignant plea that
all citizens should be protected by the
Fifteenth Amendment and should have the
right to vote and what I want to do is
to ask you where does your contract
stand and what was so fascinating to me
was that as you talked about enhancing
fairness for seniors I saw nothing about
enhancing fairness for children and
let's look at the record a higher
proportion of babies are born at low
birth weight in the United States than
in 31 other countries including Romania
Greece Turkey and Portugal the United
States ranks 19th among developed
countries for infant mortality rates the
United States ranks 17th among all
nations in the percentage of 1 year olds
who are fully immunized against polio
we're only 17th we're behind Romania
albania greece North Korea and Pakistan
and in some American cities between 10
to 42 percent of the children starting
school have not received critical
immunization long time and I'm reading
from government data which no one
challenges and our polio immunization
for children of color ranks just 70th in
the world this country where the polio
vaccine was discovered
with a great pharmaceutical companies
distributed where we brag about having
some of the finest research physicians
in the world and we are 70th in the
world
I'm frightened by your contract new but
let me point out a couple other folks to
you I'm for the work ethic but what is
your answer for the fact that the number
of people living in poverty was reported
last year to have risen to fourteen
point seven percent of the entire
population they rise for the third
straight year what is your answer to the
poverty rate among African Americans was
33 percent and for Hispanics over 29
percent and what is your response to the
fact that one of four American children
live in poverty weren't those twenty
five percent of our kids entitled to at
least a page in your book about fairness
for children in the third quarter of
last year the national unemployment rate
was approximately six point six percent
but for African Americans twelve point
six percent according to the National
Urban League because of the total
underemployment that it was probably 13
percent unemployment to 23 percent
unemployment where is the contract of
America going to give us some solace I
hope that you will read Barbara
Streisand
extraordinary and brilliant speech given
at the Kennedy School last week you know
we are we've got a fine communication
system up here in heaven we pick up all
of the shows and all the documentaries
and this is what she said I'm worried
about the direction in which the new
Congress noun seeks to take the country
she goes on to say we are all normal
Americans with her problems and
complexities including people in my
community this notion of normal America
has a horrible historical echo it
priests presupposes that there are
abnormal Americans who are responsible
for all that is wrong the new scapegoats
are members of what Genrich calls the
counterculture McGovern aches and she
concludes I did concerts for George
McGovern in 1972 and I still think that
he would have made a better president
than Richard Nixon I'm disappointed that
I've read so little in defense of
McGovern was McGovern countercultural
the son of a Republican Methodist
minister has been married to the same
woman for 51 years and flew 35 combat
missions in World War two isn't it odd
that his patriotism be disputed by a
person who never served in the military
and his own family history can hardly be
called exemplary these are tough words
mr. speaker but yet I think they have
great relevance black people are scared
profoundly scared when you talk about
contract with American because there
were contracts which caused us to come
over in slave ships
there were contracts which caused
mothers to lose their children at slave
auctions as masters sold kids where a
mother would never see her child and
these sales of human beings were
contracts and we're legitimized so
therefore mr. speaker what I really hope
is that you understand the words equity
that you have a field for justice so
that those who are weak those who are
poor that those who have no political
constituency can be the beneficiaries of
America's extraordinary resources and I
don't know whether mr. speaker I can
reach you and maybe I can't you've got a
successful formula
you've got more white males voting for
you than ever somehow or another they
seem to feel that they're being cut out
but I think to some extent well I would
hope that those people who say they
believed in my dream that they would
remember the extraordinary message which
Rabbi France gave as he spoke at the
march on Washington in 1963 he said when
I was the rabbi of the Jewish community
in Berlin under the Hitler regime I
learnt many things the most important
thing that I learned in my life under
tragic circumstances is a bigotry and
hatred are not the most urgent problem
the most urgent
most disgraceful the most shameful and
the most tragic problem is silence a
great people which had created a great
civilization had become a nation of
silent pong workers they remain silent
in the face of hatred they remained
silent and the face of brutality they
remained silent in the face of mass
murder and I hope that in our country
that the vast majority of the American
people will not remain silent
will not think that through some magic
wand you can disregard these incredible
health figures of this incredible
unemployment and this destruction of the
family and if I could pass on one final
message to you mr. speaker
forget about your contract and forget
about the political rhetoric which will
make you even more successful George
Wallace did well when he said
segregation now segregation forever and
he kept getting larger and larger and
larger votes and then shortly before his
death he was asked then in a wheelchair
then in pain said you stood in front of
the door condemning the President of the
United States because he was enforcing a
decree of the United States Supreme
Court to let one black woman autherine
Lucy get in to the Alabama school and
you called the tyranny that the Supreme
Court was imposing and you pledged that
you would change conditions at the White
House
and now mr. Wallace if you had to do it
over again do you think you should have
done it and his answer was no authoring
Lucy should have been accepted the
University of Alabama should not have
been necessary to call out thousands of
troops there or an Arkansas Little Rock
or an Oxford Mississippi
so therefore Mr Speaker I beg of you to
not think about that which will be most
politically effective because you can
probably win that way and leave the
country torn asunder and what I would
ask of you is to understand that great
poet Langston Hughes who said there's a
dream and the land with its back against
the wall by muddled names and strange
sometimes the dream is called though
those who claim this dream for theirs
alone they sent for which we know they
must atone Allah shared in common like
sunlight and like here the dream will
die for a lack of substance anywhere the
dream knows no frontier or tongue the
dream no class or race the dream cannot
be kept secure and any one locked place
this dream today embattled with its back
against the wall to save the dream for
one it must be saved for all
[Applause]
thank you
judge higginbothem jr. I appreciate you
sharing your wisdom and I admire your
courage for sharing your clear vision
thank you I'd like to take this time to
make the following announcements
immediately following this program in
the kreski Lobby there will be a
reception for judge higginbothem jr. and
of course all are invited to attend
other dr. Martin Luther King activities
include a free jazz concert which will
be here on Saturday at 8 p.m.
given by semina McCord and associates it
is at a p.m. it's free and it's open to
all the members of the MIT community and
the surrounding area also Professor
Melvin king in the community Fellows
Program will be sponsoring a youth
program throughout the weekend to close
our program MS Miriam Rosenbloom will
give the benediction
we have gathered together today on to
invoke the spirit of Martin Luther King
jr. as we say in Hebrew zucrow no Liv
raha may his memory be an everlasting
blessing in our lives now and forever at
this moment we appeal to the holy one of
being with our heartfelt prayers that
God may guide us in our strivings to
fashion all God's children with minds
that seek truth and justice with hearts
that yearn for love and beauty with
voices and bodies that promote equality
and acceptance may we display charity
and understanding to our fellow human
beings whose beliefs and forms of
expressions may be different than ours
widen the expanses of our hearts that we
may come to realize the same joy
envisioned by King David in the Bible
when he said and I read first in Hebrew
he named motto uma nyum Sheva Akeem gam
Yahud behold how good and how pleasant
it is for brothers and sisters to dwell
together in peace
our program has now ended thank you for
coming
[Applause]